WE ARE CALLING THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO ORDER.
SINCE WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM
WE'RE GOING AWAY TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM BUT SINCE MISS OR WHAT IS
HERE TO PRESENT.
A. B..
TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE IF WE
COULD CALL HER UP TO THE PODIUM
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
NINE.
HANG.
AB TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO NOTIFY THE AUTHOR OF
ENACTED LEGISLATION.
IT'S THE DEPARTMENT SUBMITS A
DRAFT BUDGET TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD DELAY THE
EFFECTIVE DATE OR MODIFY THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF RECENTLY
ENACTED LEGISLATION.
I DURING THE CONSIDERATION OF
THE TWENTY SIXTEEN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN BUDGET A HANDFUL OF
BUDGET TRAILER BILL THAT
INCLUDED LANGUAGE SEEKING TO
UNDO LEGISLATION THAT HAD BEEN
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR THE YEAR
BEFORE.
SO OF AB THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT
IRWIN A. B. NINETEEN NINETY
THREE IRWIN HEY BE TWENTY TO
SIXTY THREE BAKER AND SP FIVE
TWO FOUR LARA. ALL HAD TRAILER
BILLS THAT ADDED LANGUAGE TO
INDEFINITELY DELAY.
IMPLEMENTATION OF BILLS THIS IS
A FUNDAMENTAL SEPARATION OF AND
AND BY THE WAY IT TOOK US A LOT
OF DIGGING TO FIGURE OUT WHICH
BILLS THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DECIDED TO.
NOT FUND.
THIS IS A FUNDAMENTAL SEPARATION
OF POWERS ISSUE WE SHOULD AT A
MINIMUM RECEIVE NOTICE IF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TRIES TO
BUREAUCRATICALLY VETO A BILL.
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS SIGNED
INTO LAW.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AIBO.
THANK YOU MISTER WENT OUT SINCE
WE HAVE AQUATIC WE TAKE WILL
PLEASE.
TING. PRESENT OBERNOLTE THERE
ARAMBULA. BLOOM.
REFERRAL BRO.
CHAPTER PARA.
CHAVIS. TO.
CHOI HERE COOPER. FONG HERE
HARPER PRESENT.
JONES SAWYER. LACKEY THEIR LIMO.
MATHIS.
MCCARTY. MEDINA.
MELENDEZ.
MULLIN MURATSUCHI O'DONNELL
PATTERSON. RUBIO.
STONE VOEPEL.
WHAT? WEBER.
WHICH.
IT'S PRETTY.
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION TO HAVE A
SECOND.
SECOND DO WE HAVE ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M NOT SEEING ANY. DO
WE HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE PUBLIC PUBLIC
COME.
SEEING NONE.
LIKE TO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND WE CALL THE VOTE.
TING.
I THINK AYE OBERNOLTE. OBERNOLTE
AYE ARAMBULA. WHO?
LIAM I THROW. CLEARER.
CLICK HERE I TRAVIS.
CHáVEZ AYE CHIU AYE CHOI
CHIU AYE CHOI AYE. CHOI AYE
COOPER.
COOPER I FONG.
FONG I HARPER.
HARPER JONES SAWYER. LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LOANS.
MATHIS BY MATHIS AYE MCCARTY.
MEDINA I'D
MEDINA AYE MELENDEZ.
MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL
AYE PATTERSON.
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE STONE.
STONE AYE VOEPEL.
WEBER.
WEBER I WOULD.
WOULD AYE. ICT NO ZERO.
THANK YOU OH WILL HOLD THE ROLE
BUT FOR A FEW MORE MINUTES TO
ADD ANY ABSENT MEMBERS.
I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT
SPECIFICALLY.
THEY COMMISERATE
MELENDEZ MULLIN DOES I.
PATTERSON PATTERSON AYE
.
MCCARTY MCCARTY I
WE WE ONLY HAD ONE BILL ON. THE
AGENDA WHICH IS.
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OUR ONCE A. B..
TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE.
WHICH I HAS.
ALL ALL YES VOTES A NO NO BUT AT
THIS POINT.
VOEPEL I.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I.
MULLIN.
MULLIN I
JONES SAWYER.
I AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
THANK YOU AND WE ARE RETURNING
BUDGET COMMITTEE